they listened to the evidence presented
and they rendered a decision if some to
choose to protest they must peacefully
demonstrate that is they're right but I
also want to be very very clear about
any potential disturbances in our city
we are prepared to respond
we want to thank the hard-working jury
for that service to the public and
they're correct with gesture then that
purple personal sacrifice for their time
and effort we ask the public to remain
calm patient because we are confident
that will be another trial with a
different jury will call you should be
calm too
boundaries are not unusual approximately
five percent of all the criminal cases
that are tried in the country result in
hung juries most of them are we
prosecuted